this is a production of Cornell
University
so what I'm going to talk to you about
today is kind of title doesn't say much
I suppose and this research grew out of
my PhD work and it was kind of a chance
discovery and to give you an idea of how
I ended up working on this and why why
we ended up going down this I'm going to
give a little bit of background so my
PhD was on natural genetic variation in
photosynthesis and basically the
rationale behind it was to look at what
variation is there to see if we can find
we were doing G wasps and a couple of
other things genes relevant for this
variation which potentially could be
used for improving crops and the likes
and in order to do that we had to come
up with a way of phenotyping
photosynthesis which is not so easy it's
kind of an elusive phenotype so we
developed this system which could
measure 1440 plants in less than an hour
for photosynthetic efficiency and it
could also measure a couple of other
things so as well as photosynthesis
which we measured using chlorophyll
fluorescence which gives us these kind
of images here we also measure growth
rate which for arabidopsis is pretty
easy because it's got this flat
architecture so you can just get an idea
of plant size by measuring projected
leaf area and from this we got other
information such as lief movement and
that's because as you can see here more
or less with the pointer these leaves
the plants are getting bigger and
smaller and that's not because they're
actually getting bigger and smaller it's
because their leaves are going up and
down so you get a lot of other
information from these plots and also we
had a spectral filters we were able to
measure its specific wavelengths of
light which gave us an idea of different
pigment content in the leaves and to
sign in chlorophyll things like that but
today I'm going to focus on
photosynthesis and not on what was the
primary research but one of the
spin-offs of this so I measured this
population of plants a rabid officers
collected from all over the world so we
had 700 accessions genotyped with
214,000 snips and took quite some time
even to measure that number because we
did a lot of replicates and to get good
robust data and this was the phenotypic
distribution that came out of it and as
you can see here we have this nice no
normal distribution here of all the
individuals so here on the x axis we
have photosynthetic efficiency and on
the y axis with the number of
individuals in each bin and but we have
these guys down here which were really
different from everybody else and it
turned out that these plants were all of
one particular genotype which had
considerably reduced photosynthesis I
was pretty excited when I first came
across this because I thought oh this is
really cool we found something new and
then when I looked into it I discovered
somebody had already published on this
except it had a different accession name
so we didn't know it was in our
collection and what it was was a
genotype which was herbicide-resistant
it was resistant to triazine herbicides
this plant had been collected in the
1980s in a railway track in England and
basically it been in stock center since
then one of the concerts what this
herbicide does is it targets at the
photosystem 2 unit of photosynthesis so
it hits this protein here it is a
photosystem protein d1 and what happens
normally with this d1 protein is that
plus the Queen all binds here and gets
its the primary electron acceptor which
moves electrons down into a linear
electron transport pathway and what's
important for binding is this Syrian
here you see there's a hydrogen bonding
site and atrazine gets in there as well
these or any of these triazines and
blocks this pocket so that the electron
transport fo can no longer work the
plant has an energy crisis and it dies
so the herbicides very effective but the
mutation which has evolved actually in
72 different species so it's a great
example of convergent evolution results
in this Syrian being substituted with a
glycine the atrazine no longer bonds
efficiently and the plant becomes
resistant to this herbicide but a
consequence of course is that the
plastic we know also doesn't bond as
well so the photosynthetic efficiency is
greatly lowered so that was that
basically we had this plant which was
herbicide resistant and basically you
know they've already been described so
that was fine but one of the problems
was and I think I actually took this
slide out which was silly it had a big
reduction in growth rate efficiency as
well which basically I come up with a
way of swapping the chloroplasts around
so what we have here is we have the
normal wild-type which has this reduced
photosynthetic efficiency of sixteen
percent but we then gave it a wild-type
chloroplast and we get this increased
growth rate of 87 sorry oh it's so it's
a coral so it's for the system to
efficiency and it's a good proxy for
carbon dioxide assimilation rate it's
not exactly the same but it's similar so
it goes up two units of the maximum
possible efficiency for dark-adapted
leaves its point 83 so it goes from zero
2.83 it cannot go any higher than that
and usually plants under steady state
conditions so adapted to light growth
they're operating around between point
six and point seven and these guys are
down in most cases around depending on
the light intensity around point for
point five so they've got a considerable
drop this was at very low light levels
this was at one hundred micromoles of
light so the actual efficiency in
photosynthesis drop is only sixteen
percent but it has a big impact on
growth rates because the plants are when
they have this reduced chloroplast
efficiency effectively working at
probably their light compensation point
so the point of which the energy input
is only just about enough to keep the
plant going so it's growth rate is it's
very much so compromised is that did
that answer your question okay so the
problem with this was that I wanted to
use this data for genome-wide
Association mapping and genome-wide
Association mapping works fine when your
blow sire on the nuclear genome so I had
these 214,000 snips or located on the
nuclear genome however this mutation is
in the PSP a protein which is
chloroplast encoded and when I included
this genotype in my
she was approached it completely messed
up the results so I got lots of false
positives so this is what was keeping
this genotype in my mind because and I
did some other research to overcome this
issue but it was always there was kind
of a thing that was bugging me and i
discovered this at the beginning of my
PhD found that had already been
published on but it was still fresh in
my mind and i happened to be in norwich
here in England giving a talk and Ely is
nearby and this was the wrong time of
the year this is August this is not the
time of the year that you go collecting
a rabid opsys but I you know how to
spare a couple of hours I grabbed the
train i went down to ely railway station
now most people had thought people that
originally published this knew it was
collected 1988 it was collected but the
herbicides triazines were banned or
discontinued in europe in 1992 everybody
assumed this thing had died out and I
was kind of curious the see whether
indeed it had died out and if it was
still there what was the frequency and
it would be a nice example I thought of
studying photosynthesis in the field
here we have a mutant which occurred in
nature with a reduced photosynthetic
efficiency how does it interact with
plants would hire photosynthesis because
there's a lot of debate in world
photosynthesis whether it actually is
limiting for plants or is it something
that the wild plants really need at a
high level and we thought we could
answer a lot of interesting questions so
I went there to ely railway station I
looked around and it was the wrong time
of year but I found these little
skeletons of dead plants with a couple
of seeds still stuck on and I was pretty
excited about this and I brought them
back to the lab and this is a picture of
the railway station here we have the
station near the railway tracks and this
is going into the city and I found
plants here in the car park and I tested
them to see if they were resistant and
like I said most people had thought that
it probably would have died out and they
were all resistant I was like oh this is
pretty cool this is interesting it's
still there let's go back now the
assumption at this point was that it had
originated in Ely railway station and
that because that's where it was first
collected in the 80s and there was no
reason to think otherwise so we had
these grand ideas of doing transects
away from the railway station seeing how
far it's spread and what was the
interaction between resistant and
non-resistant genotypes now that the
selective advantage was removed the
herbicide was no longer in the
environment and how much of a cost is
this reduced photosynthesis in nature
and when I went back then in May 2013
because I basically convinced my
supervisors that this was something we
had to do so they were willing to pay
for that this is the revered else is
growing in the railway ballast here and
here was just some sampling we went back
again to Ely so here's the railway
station which I showed you a picture of
before and we started sampling all over
to town or we tried to we couldn't find
any rubber topsis outside the railway
station well we found a couple but we
were like walking around this town for
two days looking at every corner and we
really couldn't find anything really I
was really disappointed I was like well
where is all the arabidopsis and then we
did a little bit of research into the
history of Ely and it turns out Ely is
actually a clay island which was
surrounded by fan or bog arabidopsis
doesn't really like clay and it
certainly doesn't grow on bog and these
fans had already been drained in the
past hundred years so it was not prime
Arab adoptions territory and you'll
notice down here so this is the railway
track coming down we had one plant
collected also along the railway track
just a bit further awakes we walk down
this road and that plant was also
resistant so then we started thinking so
any Arab adopts this is probably not
native to Ely it probably came in on the
railway tracks and railway tracks are
good or avid offices habitat they've got
sand they've got rock and they're
relatively free of competition so we
thought didn't originate here and it
must have come from somewhere else so
let's sample along the railway tracks
and see if we can track out where it
came from so we went back a month later
and I did I basically just took lots of
trains all over this part of England and
we I sampled all these railway stations
which I regretted that in the end I
should have rented a car said read
trains don't go out very often and
sometimes you spent two or three hours
and some dumped somewhere no way out and
which happened this place can it I hope
nobody's from kennett of stuck there for
ages anyway so went around collecting I
found the rubber tops is pretty much in
all the railway stations almost and then
all of these places there were resistant
genotypes so this resistance had spread
quite far we know
they actually how far it's spread
because we didn't go beyond like it
hasn't stopped so we've got really
interested in this and thought well this
must have spread all over the place and
we're not going to be able to track it
down because we don't know which
direction to go in there's not enough
information from this where it came from
so we thought well let's have a look at
what's available in the genotype data
bases and see what's related to this
resistant individual that we have
genetic markers for we had 214,000
markers and there was this reg map panel
available of 1307 plans all of which had
been genotyped with these 214,000
markers so we did basically a
relatedness essay and we have this one
genotype which was much more closely
related than anything else to this
resistant individual so we thought okay
that's a good starting point where is
this genotype from and this genotype is
from here ledbury and basically near the
Welch border in England but Ely is here
so they're quite far away so we told
maybe maybe it really has spread very
far and then we told well what else can
we do what other information can we use
to get an idea of where it is originated
from and we thought well there's another
genotype data set it's got a lot more
plants almost 6,000 but it's got a lot
less markers but still we might be able
to get some information from this so we
basically plotted the possible origins
all these yellow dots aware genotypes
were collected from and this color so
dark means less likely to be from there
and white means more likely so we had
this hope that we would get a nice idea
of these purple lines by the way the
railway tracks where it came from as you
can see it's not very obvious this is
not very informative there's a few
locations where we're pretty sure it's
not from better than that it could be
from anywhere here even it looks like
could be from northern France which I
don't believe so this didn't work as
well as one would hope one would hope
but in this set of six thousand lines
there were four that were identical for
all 149 markers to the Ely genotype and
when I check them and I genotype them
pretty mutation every single one of them
was resistant so they were the same
plant from the same mutation event so
this was pretty interesting and where
they were from is even further away it
was down in Cornwall this is about 400
kilometers
crow flies between these two locations
so we thought well we want to
investigate that is this a little bit
more see how far it's really spread so
we'll do a sampling strategy around this
area of southwest England because we had
these two data points pointing us in
this direction so we went back again
with a lot more sampling wrong railway
tracks here we haven't actually a
herbicide not try as eens of course they
don't spray them anymore probably
glyphosate or something arab adopts us
along the railway tracks and we went to
ledbury as well and we're bit
disappointed so in total including the
sampling in the East of England we had
573 plants collected and in total we got
52 resistant plants but in the southwest
apart from the place where they had
originally been collected from are these
sick for individuals in this panel of
6000 we didn't find it back there so it
may have gone extinct although that
railway station was being renovated at
the time so the place was completely
destroyed and we didn't find much in the
way of arabidopsis in the actual station
but I did find it out here and were
chester independently so we do not have
it has spread quite considerable
distances again all these brownish lines
are railway tracks and this is the
original area that we sampled and you
can see there's quite a lot of plants
from there one thing that was
interesting about it was that it was
completely associated with railway
tracks so when we sampled we sampled on
railway tracks and we always went away
into the town and tried to get non
railway track samples and never did we
find the resistance away from the
railways so it was 100% association with
the railways so this was something that
evolved on our new railway track and
then spread all around the place so the
next question was well was this a single
event so we have these 52 plants
collected from different parts of
England was it one mutation event or
didn't involve multiple times because
bear in mind this mutation has evolved
and seventy two separate occasions in
different species so it's something that
seems to evolve relatively regularly in
response to try an application and we
just did a simple we didn't use a lot of
markers I don't think we needed them we
had 32 snips spread across the genome
and we genotyped all of the 500 plans to
get an idea and every single resistant
individual was down here so they were
all completely identical for all 32
snips
so for medias was pretty convincing that
it was one mutation event which then
spread and this is where the hitchhiking
comes in because then we started
thinking about this and what does this
actually mean and I'm going to explain
genetically choking just as a refresher
for those of you are not familiar with
it and this is genetically choking in
the nucleus so here we have basically a
piece of DNA and each of these lines
represents different individuals in a
population the colorful blocks represent
snips or polymorphisms with reference to
one another if one of these individuals
gets a mutation which is beneficial in
some way and then it starts rising in
frequency you get what's known as a
selective sweep and this would be the
post selective sweet population so you
see that obviously this is much more
common because it adds a benefit but the
interesting thing to pay attention to is
that these polymorphisms which provide
no direct fitness advantage have also
rises in frequency and this is because
of this physical linkage to the selected
locus they're literally linked
physically on the DNA and this is
classical genetics week but it does
depend on physical linkage in the
classical understanding of it and that
all occurs in nucleus because you've got
these big chromosomes you've got
recombination there however our mutation
is on the chloroplasts which is
obviously not physically linked to any
low sigh in the nucleus yet we had
complete fixation of these nuclear
genomes so these nuclear genomes had
arisen to this frequency purely on the
back of this chloroplast mutation so
they're basically as I said hitched a
ride on this chloroplast so as I said
genetic linkage is something which is
generally assumed to occur in only when
things are physically linked and it's
restricted by recombination it's a very
important phenomenon and it's recently
been shown to resolve lewins paradox
which is this basically according to
neutral theory in evolution there should
be a linear relationship between
population size and genetic diversity
but that is not the case the larger the
population the lower the genetic
diversity is compared to what one would
expect and this has been recently I mean
it's been often considered that
selection is the cause of this selection
will operate more efficiently in large
populations and we
of this physical linkage when you get
selection you get a region around it
which is reduced in diversity so
basically what you're happening it's
called genetic draft this when
hitchhiking occurs across the whole
genome the phenomena is genetic draft
you're dragging the diversity down this
does happen in larger populations so
it's a very important phenomena but it's
always assumed exclusively to occur
within the nucleus there's no literature
considering how selection on organelles
could affect nuclear diversity and
that's because there's no physical
linkage so I think people don't really
think about it here we're showing that
there has been very strong selection on
an organelle which has resulted in a
complete change in the diversity of
nuclear genomes in these populations of
arabidopsis now this is probably because
the rabid opsys is highly inbreeding so
you don't have a physical linkage but
you have a statistical linkage and how
important the level of inbreeding is
compared to the intensity of selection
is something that we don't know but
we're thinking about so basically what
i'm showing is something very simple but
what's interesting about it is that it
hasn't been observed before and it
hasn't really been considered in the
literature how does selection on
organelles indirectly affect nuclear
genetic diversity and this I think it's
particularly interesting because it's
becoming more and more obvious that
there is indeed a lot of selection on
organelles so if you look at southern
hemisphere beech trees not the focus the
basically the diversity of the
organelles doesn't match up with the
diversity of the nuclear genomes the
diversity organelles shows a latitudinal
gradient some organelles are better
adapted to different temperatures and
these move actually between species the
nuclear genetic diversity don't match so
you've got strong selection on these
organelles for adaptation to these
different climatic zones and if you have
such kind of selection you potentially
as we show here can have linkage these
processes could cause distortions in
nuclear gene frequencies which is
basically what I'm getting the question
is does it require inbreeding or any
level of inbreeding and this will
require modeling to go forward with this
so in summary the main point I'm getting
at is that selection on organelles can
affect nuclear genetic diversity and so
a lot of people that I've tried to
explain is to found it a bit confusing
and wanted me to illustrate it better so
I thought about it quite long and hard
as hell
show this and it sort of sophisticated
and clear way and I came up with
basically this figure which I think
aptly shows how the organelles can
distort nuclear gene frequencies and
that is basically what i wanted to show
to you today I've gone through it a
little bit fast I see but there are some
remaining questions things that need to
be addressed of course so how common is
this and I think this is a particularly
interesting question we were very lucky
so we stumbled upon this which is what I
was trying to get out the way I told the
story we were not looking for this we
were I was interested in photosynthesis
and then we came across this phenomena
we knew the Selective agent we knew the
locus which was providing resistance we
had all this prior information then we
had this nice system of railway tracks
and we had the region where the
Selective agent was applied and where it
wasn't so it's very clear that selection
was occurring on the chloroplast there
is no doubt about that and then we were
able to see that the nuclear genome at
hitchhiked along but when you actually
know that the chloroplast is on the
selection the Selective agent and the
site of selection is pretty rare so if
you don't have the prior knowledge we
have how would you be able to find these
phenomena which i think is an
interesting question because almost all
of the population genetic studies
looking at the effect of these kind of
selective sweeps is exclusively looking
at diversity in the nuclear genome and
they pretty much ignore what's going on
in the organelles even though they can
be on the selection a lot so basically
how do we detect it and what are the
evolutionary consequences of this does
it distort nuclear genetic diversity as
much as we now realize genetic draft
operating within the nucleus can distort
nuclear genetic diversity how big an
impact canopy because like i said it's
becoming more and more clear that there
is a lot of selection operating on
organelles and if the selection is also
distorting nuclear gene frequencies what
kind of consequences could this have for
evolution like i said it can lead to a
lawsuit and another thing is the inter
genome conflicts so these organelles
have to communicate with the nucleus
it's a very tight relationship to
regulate all of this so if you've got 1g
organelle increasing
but lien frequency due to selection then
the associated nuclear genomes if any of
them are less well adapted to this and
you can have also distortions there so
that's basically it I've gone faster
than I expected I probably skipped
something I didn't do this alone of
course I've got this was stuffed like I
said that grew out of my PhD research so
my two supervisors mark and Jeremy
promoter Martin karnath who basically
made sure that I graduated and then help
in the lab from Frank and from bus these
two guys helped me out with like just
basic stuff in the lab helping along and
then a lot of the analysis i did with a
guy called the austin hey garden which
was very very helpful and you know with
that I thank you for your attention and
I hope that maybe you have some
questions or comments really did that
little bit more of the molecular making
this how the environment
well so does in brief is like trains
that sprayed herbicide so that's been
that's the environmental pressure at
these special friends that they designed
and driving on railway tracks spraying
website keep them clear so this is the
Selective pressure effectively and then
you it not Sarah Fossett this is you get
a simple amino acid substitution which
provides resistance and then this plant
is occurring on a railway track which as
these trains moving non well with
herbicide spraying trains moving up and
down it nay has been quite a lot of
evidence to show they produced these
wind effects which distributes scenes
people different stuff in their shoes so
there's lots of wait for it dispersal on
railway tracks and liberal way stations
so I think that's how it actually spread
so I think it's a nice example of
congruence between human induced
chemical changes and human created
infrastructure providing avenues for
changes in genética populations that was
clear but that was in the molecular and
cellular
as fresh air
the neck driving the collection so under
other examples and mammals or
and the essential
there is evidence there's plenty of
evidence of selection occurring them
organelles but this is the first time
anybody's ever in this way of telling
the story anybody's ever considered that
the selection on the organelle can
distort new routine frequencies through
this effectively itchy certain
statistical think it's not a physical or
biological connection is just by chance
is it's a stochastic effect it's
organelle the protein is nucular genetic
background generate an egg background
got a free ride and the I'm answering
yes you're happy for ya so because there
is evidence of organelles being
important for lots of things in plants
they're important for water use
efficiency so it's been really nice
studies done using a reciprocal
transplants of some flowers which have
they been progressive basically they
made a super cool real population so
reciprocal savory any populations and
they've been able to show it at the
cytoplasmic background I don't know
whether they were able to show it
because it's difficult disentangle the
nucleus earlier faster than my country
is there always inherited together at
least in most organisms and they were to
show that these had a big impact on for
example survival to drought and it was
an example of local adaptation of these
so that was like really nice and very
cool studies but then you also see like
I mentioned with the southern hemisphere
peach you see he's like really nice
latitudinal stratification of different
more glasses but not the nuclear genome
because
the mitochondrial genome duplication as
well or in the evolution of jinan
sometimes we have is to forget particles
of genomes see any duplication of my
vagina Hey well it does happen you have
what is it is it mine species with this
massive mitochondrial genome in its side
in a witch just expands dramatically but
are you wondering about like when
polyploidy happens or yeah really fun
well polyploidy is just something that
happens in the nucleus because
mitochondria for bus is already are
effectively polypoid just as many copies
of the main every cell so i left thank
you whatever caused me like i can
imagine a situation where you have both
the wild side and i would be
advantageous for a platform that's a
really good question and we never found
it so i checked for a plasma we never
found it in arabidopsis but it was a
nice science paper published in i think
it was the late 80s or early nineties oh
forget Kentucky language has almost
never been cited interesting and which
they showed that what was the species
senecio had heteroplasmy for resistance
and non-resistant go fast and it has way
of maintaining this type of but me which
is most interesting because a lot of
people study had proposed me in tissue
culture in the 1990s and then they did
these product last fusions and then you
get like a mixed
by of organelles and almost always it
segregates have rapidly so you get one
crunch which has one particular Corvus
another branch was another mitochondria
are being more promiscuous often they
actually mix 30 notes you get inside
there my country the chloroplasts don't
do that these three literature i bred so
usually is the assumption is that had
four blood moons never really maintain
its lost out during mitosis but this
organism was able to maintain and
philosophy very interestingly when they
subjected its selection so for example
the strong herbicide application it went
to homo plasma of resistant genotypes
and it never went back after that so
obviously the knowledge system points
have gone extinct it's somehow but in
the absence of the airside applications
somehow therefore maintain nobody's that
already followed that up and that's the
only known example our case so you
didn't go into this but at the beginning
you show the plot with it photosynthetic
efficiency
and seems to be a complex and you said
if we wanted Fugee us but we never
really worked you actually wanted it to
look at nuclear genes so yeah that would
be in a different talk and what and yet
to answer your question yes indeed if he
was we found someone outside and it was
I was young it's very and it wasn't it
was like I don't know does anybody here
done he was on complex rights ya done it
were you happy with okay so basically my
answer will be was pretty for me I
thought it was a bit disappointing or
because was oversold to me and I was
very global believe all the stories I
was told but in the end most of the
large effect goes I like the large eglo
say we come had already be found for
disease resistance for the defects
photosynthesis because it gives an
autoimmune
basically plants are killing games
before other plants so you see this
coming off of the master production
photosynthetic efficiency we did find
other low side when I didn't manage in
time I have to play a little
characterized and police what they made
sense in certain genes no this didn't
make any sense whatsoever what we did
find stuff that's what you were
wondering about I can't like it I can
help you I can show you what I've done
later from camera but all of the so she
goes I'm completely on board with your
concept that nuclear genes can hitchhike
with big organelle but I'm skeptical as
to whether you really have an example of
that and the reason I'm skeptical is
that triazine resistance has a rising
spraying has been used that long so this
this plant could have arisen perhaps on
your birthday and there you were born
and then these plants are actually
fairly young like you so how do we know
they've had enough time for the nuclear
variation to occur that it retin it
rather than it's simply being that they
haven't had enough time to get old and
change so do you have a way to refute my
my skepticism I have to be honest I
don't understand what you so here's my
theory the reason you're finding all the
nuclear genomes the same as they simply
haven't had enough time to change
especially since you've gotten
inbreeding species alright if you have
an out crossing species then i would
agree there must be some reason that
they're staying the same but you have an
inbreeding species these moments could
be in or no I understand your question
yeah the fact that there is same is not
a problem for me
that doesn't mean that the hitchhiking
hasn't occurred it means that the
hitchhiking was extremely tight linkage
I think was if the interesting is why
did we never see how cross why did we
never see a individual which had the
resistant chloroplasts which was at how
the mixed nuclear Tina time and I think
the answer doesn't we don't have been to
enough sampling basically I think it's
probably out there but it occurs a
little frequency because like you say a
rabid opsys is highly in reading the
fact that we see no differences is a
combination of fact we've only got 22
snips I think we did whole genome
sequencing we see more polymorphisms 32
states is not a lot and it doesn't mean
a lot of time but that doesn't mean that
HIV has not occurred unless I miss for
the city no I so I guess my point is you
haven't proven that as is has occurred
because you simply don't have enough
time and arabidopsis has a fairly low
outcrossing frequency i guess i don't
know in England it's imagine somebody's
measured how much outcrossing happens in
nature and do you have any idea what
perky nose cut it out crossing frequency
between so you saw like point 95 in
reading
almost so that's really what i'm saying
i think i completely ablute believe that
the nuclear genome it is probably
dragged along with with the organelle
gentleman under many circumstances since
there are protein complexes in the
chloroplasts that are from both you know
made by x from both nuclear and
organelle genes you would imagine that
there are some some reason that you
would want to have nuclear genes of fit
best with the organelle genome but i
just don't think you have shown it yet
with you know the metadata that you have
but i'm not suggesting that there is a
correlation between these two this
nucleus and a support us no i'm not
suggesting that either i'm just saying
that unless you have more time in more
plants and you know more outcrossing i
think it's hard to say that the reason
that those nuclear genomes are all the
same is because of dragging along the
nuclear genome with the organization
what would be the alternative hypothesis
that how else would they be all the same
that simply hasn't been enough
outcrossing and you haven't collect
enough friends to see the ones that have
crossed so you know you could be you
could be right i just think i wouldn't
want more proof okay that's why not
accept that but i still don't i don't
really get why this I don't get it
basically what the point is that they're
all the same is that's the evidence but
that's not me I'm just saying that your
evidence isn't strong enough yet okay I
need more plans more markers and you
know to look for whether they really are
all the same or whether they just
haven't had enough time to help cross
and I mean these plants could have
arisen in 1990 and well they well they
were connected in 1988 as I said behind
your za Charlie things were sprayed in
England since nineteen sixty most
evidence regarding the rate of evolution
of resistance is that it happens with
entertaining for 10 years in most
instances so probably it was around
since the 70s that's still not a lot of
time but the fact that they're all
identical is like me know it was one
event and this nuclear genome has
nothing to do with resistance yet is
that much higher frequency as a
consequence so it is very definition of
these
sound of genetic a shocking but if
another population spawned from a single
ancestor in 1970 and you tracked that
population I've looked at the variation
you know they both started at the same
time and I merged would that have as
many differences either over that have
many differences or with all the genomes
formed by that population all right
seeing those populations at the same way
of looking at this is that try zooming
essentially extinguish all other
competitively Regina so there's really
nothing left even if they're out
crossing you still the same nuclear
issue so you have inbreeding going on in
getting incredibly intense way yes and
that probably occurred when it's red but
now that we go by the example these
plants are a mix of styles with others
speak with no with other message
individuals yeah so it did possibility
are crossing certainly there yep and
what's not a possible if you've got a
customer as long as that
yes well so you really have the time the
opportunity
from the time they stopped the actual
truth and when was that base 92 yeah so
so you basically have 20 at most 25
years or something to explore other
nuclear genomes as a post-dated court
but so I comin in reading any evidence
it's not that strong but I agree with
you but the thing is that the nuclear
genome has already increased massively
and frequency so even as it ever crosses
I'm and this nuclear genome gets into
other organ air backgrounds and vice
versa it has massively increased in
frequency it's a rare genotype we switch
over the relation is apart from the
resistant individuals we don't find many
times supposed to relate all of England
or in northwestern Europe it's kind of
an odd one out thing is now it's at a
much higher frequency in an editor was
before which is beside me as I
understand it it could also be seen as a
fog effect I mean it's essentially what
you have it's like an island that it's a
long railway
I mean if they didn't receive durable
aside from hell no every site is
definitely gone also because there's
species of bacteria which evolved to eat
it as a nitrogen source but you can also
see that upon the fact I here with you
about hitchhiking but when I found the
reflected in checking our heart our two
sides of the same point as I understand
it's just a look of association with a
particular locus that gives you to our
frequency or the look of getting on the
island first that is hiking occurs with
more individuals are competing and I
guess it's take a chiropractor small
sample size that goes through okay yeah
depend around the region where is
selection occurs in the genome it's
effectively like a founder effect right
okay well I'm always really that goes
with that kinda sad would be to just
walk for this simulation and just find
exactly what that happened but you could
answer what I would need sequence start
again be able to get out the signals but
since you have a couple of snips to have
a vacation
no clear polymorphisms in yellow they're
completely identical for all 32 states
of the new cochlear neutrogena thank you
yeah it's right across to you so there
it is it's continuing reading are you
suggesting but I think the reason we
haven't how many ever you need a lot
more simply you find at the rate of
everything that would hurt okay I have
an experiment for you to do okay all
right you show them your little map that
you had some railway stations where
there were non triazine resistant and
try seemed resistant plants why not
collect seeds and then see if there's
any outcrossing and if you're saying
that the reason was those plants are all
one nuclear genome is because there's
been selection for them why don't you
measure the rate of outcrossing in those
regions where the plants are located i'm
trying to do that and money
i would like to i did find somehow no
crossing in a non-existent en place so
there were 7 episode gossipy so there is
no crossing occurring in these
populations I was just never looking on
find one which I've crossed with a
resistant or resistant month which had
any degree of crossing man surrounded
and it is compatible it does may get one
this is perfectly cross-pollinate a book
that's not there's no physiological
barrier to prevent this well but maybe
there is a nature maybe for some reason
that planet is less likely to help cross
in nature they flower at the same time
so there's no sort of making in nature
and they're all flowering one I like
it's possible of course I cannot move it
out but I never how many of its to
suggest that I my feeling is I just
didn't have enough samples I think if I
went back and sampled even more
intensively with like hundreds of my
screaming population I would find it
thank you and I'm across the middle I
don't remember answering your question
properly I think it was it was tapped on
to it was like an example of what
learning the same but I have a different
question about something you're gonna
get slight with you I'm not saying that
this is what happens here but could you
ever imagine a case where you have a
chloroplast gee that's so it's not
physically linked of course the nuclear
genes but there's a genetic interaction
like the proteins interact and then you
get genetic draft from not the
chloroplast gene but nuclear genes that
work well with that chloroplast genes
then you could have had centered
chloroplast having in direct genetic
drivers
and if you have something as complex as
photosynthetic machinery could you
imagine that happening like gauging
multiple sites throughout the nuclear
genome and then you can't distinguish
chloroplasts genética choking from like
in direct nuclear draft and yeah that's
the something when you I mean the best
example of that aside buzzin castor
ility where you have a nice occurs in
the mitochondria give me one example of
iterative corpus for you have some using
your proteins are involved in this
basically is a mitochondria evolves to
kill the column mitochondria is one
plants that are polymers the rationale
behind it of course it's not thinking
like this book as a selective advantage
if it's in a modern man this is more
scenes in males there are plants usually
produce more seats and then you get more
out of proxy a story so often you get
advantages of hybrid vigor and all of
that but of course as it rises in
frequency more and more plants are no
longer able to produce pollen so it
becomes an advantage to be able to
produce pollen but this side of cosmic
background is also increased in
frequency so then you get the evolution
of restore factors and you basically
have an arms race with being a nuclear
genome the mitochondria and these in
Europe proteins or the proteins that
alternative high restore factors show
very similar evolutionary package a
pattern to packaging resistant students
they occur these kind of sets of
duplicates and
so it really looks like it's sort of
almost in a new interaction between the
nucleus mitochondria so that is an
example of that in terms of like
proteins working together I make an hour
particular example so I didn't go into
it today but because this jeans like
worried me so much as it messed up my
gos results I came up with a way along
with a PhD student of using a mitotic
immune to genome Eliminator line some of
you may have heard of this nhp line from
the sun-eater to eliminate the nuclear
genome an aggressive mutation into
multiple so the cosmic background so i
made a diary of nuclear cytoplasmic
combinations complete reciprocal dying
and I included this persistent in tight
and works perfectly fine all of her side
selfies so the reason my physiological
basis for at least no evidence for
physiological basis for this association
between the core class and meticulous
what we're looking at what I argue we're
looking at is a statistical association
look at this genotype occurred is
neutrogena fight occurred with this
floor class which we've got resistant to
the herbicide arose in frequency due to
selective advantage in plastic near
habitat along the railway tracks got to
a very much you can see the Selective
pressure is no longer there it's
occurring mixed stands but the damage so
to speak is already being done
it has done the H i think it is now at a
very high frequency it has had the
benefit of being close to be associated
with this corpus which is why i argue
against connecticut hiking in the fact
that they're identical the nuclear
genome sorry enter her he's 4 30 groups
names which curly case score vast is
evidence for this time in this has been
a production of cornell university on
the web at cornell edu